[Music]
hey guys
welcome to another installment of harry
potter theory
in this video we're going to be
discussing the ministry of magic
or more specifically all of the
departments and levels that exist within
the ministry of magic
we see lots of the departments and
different departments are name-dropped
on several occasions throughout the
books and films
but i've never really thought about how
many there actually are are there any
that we don't know about
the ministry of magic is of course the
primary form of government in the
magical world
at least in the uk other countries have
a similar structure of government
but have different names i.e in the u.s
there is macusa
the magical congress of the united
states of america
like a mughal government the ministry's
responsibilities are vast
as they are the primary body that
attempt to sustain law and order in the
magical world
like any system of government in an
effort to cover as much ground as
possible
the primary governmental body is
systematically divided
to focus on different sectors of the
wizarding world the governmental body in
britain
before the ministry of magic was the
wizards council which was the
longest-serving former government that
served britain however the wizards
council lacked
structure and it was time for the
antiquated system to be redeveloped for
a more modern time
in the year 1707 the ministry of magic
that we now know
was formed a newer and more modern form
of government
that could more appropriately address
all of the concerns of the wizarding
world
while simultaneously ensuring that the
statute of secrecy was carefully upheld
the core reason for the ministry's
existence summed up quickly
is explained in this quick exchange
between harry and hagrid
ministry of magic messing things up as
usual there's a ministry of magic
course they wanted dumbledore for
minister of course but he'd never leave
hogwarts so old cornelius fudge got the
job
bungler if there ever was one so he pelt
stumbled with ours every morning
asking for advice but what does the
ministry of magic do
well their main job is to keep it from
the muggles they're still witches and
wizards up and down the country
why why blimey harry everyone would be
wanting magical solutions to their
problems
now we're best left alone this quote
highlights that with all that they take
on
their ultimate responsibility is to
ensure that there is a harmonious
and distinctly segregated relationship
with the muggle world
secrecy is of utmost importance which is
why there are such strict regulations
around underage magic
and magic in the muggle world if muggles
knew of all that goes on in the
wizarding world
then it could really cause quite the
kerfuffle however while secrecy is
important and always takes highest
priority
there are a number of sub-departments
inside the ministry that function in
order to achieve or uphold this ultimate
goal
the ministry of magic has seven separate
departments in total
which are distributed amongst the ten
levels the ministry building offers
one important thing to note is that as
the entire ministry is underground
the higher the floor number the deeper
the floor is level by level
let's see what the ministry of magic has
to offer level one
level one isn't that interesting and
does not house any particular department
the first level is used primarily as
office space for the minister of magic
who oversees all ministry operations as
well as other administrative staff
level two level two houses the
department of magical law enforcement
which is the largest department of the
ministry it's arguably the most
important department of the ministry as
well
and is responsible for ensuring that all
laws are upheld in britain's wizarding
community
heads of this department have included
bharti crouch senior amelia bones
pious thickness and others the
department of magical law enforcement
covers a lot of ground
and for this reason it is subdivided
into various divisions
these divisions are as follows firstly
we have the aura headquarters
the aura headquarters is where all of
the highest ranking members of magical
law enforcement work
auras are responsible for dealing with
and arresting all manners of dark
witches and wizards
the second division is the improper use
of magic office which is responsible for
keeping an eye on witches and wizards
and ensuring that they are not
committing violations of magic it's
likely that this office is responsible
for the trace
which alerts them when young witches and
wizards perform illegal magic
and thirdly we have the wizangamat
administration services
the wizarding mart is the court of the
wizarding world the high court of law
and parliament
the wesengamat administration services
office is responsible for any and all
paperwork
pertaining to the wazengamat
subdivisions of these core divisions
include
the administrative registration
department the department of
intoxicating substances
hit wizards the investigation department
the magical law enforcement patrol
the ministry of magic witch watchers the
misuse of muggle artifacts office
and the office of the detection and
confiscation of counterfeit defensive
spells
and protective objects level three level
three of the ministry houses the
department of magical accidents and
catastrophes
the primary function of this department
is to ensure that all magical damage
caused by accidental means are repaired
this department has three core divisions
first the accidental magical reversal
squad this division is comprised of a
team of witches and wizards who are
responsible for correcting magical
mistakes
this division is of particular
importance as it is not uncommon for
young
or inexperienced witches and wizards to
have unfavorable results when learning
magic
the second division is the obliviator
headquarters this division is
responsible for all matters related to
the well-known spell obliviate which is
used to erase memories from someone's
mind
obliviators are responsible for wiping
the memories of muggles after witnessing
acts of magic
the third division is definitely an
interesting one and is called the
muggle-worthy excuse committee the sole
responsibility of this committee
is to come up with excuses for magical
accidents or occurrences
that take place in the muggle world
level four
level four houses the department for the
regulation and control of magical
creatures
this is the second largest department in
the ministry after the department of
magical law enforcement
and is responsible for ensuring that all
manners of magical beasts
and creatures are kept in check there
are seven divisions of this department
the first is the beast division which
handles all matters pertaining to
creatures classified as beast
the second is the being division which
handles all matters pertaining to
creatures classified as
being and the third is the spirit
division which handles all matters
pertaining to creatures classified as
spirit a beast is a magical creature
that does not have sufficient
intelligence to understand laws a being
is a magical creature that
should possess sufficient intelligence
to understand laws
and the spirit is reserved primarily for
ghosts or those who have passed away
the fourth division is the goblin
liaison office which works to improve
relationships between goblins and
wizards
the fifth division is the centaur
liaison office which works in a similar
fashion to the other office but deals
with centaurs
the sixth division is the pest advisory
board which helps to deal with
infestations in wizarding homes
they're basically pest control and
lastly the seventh department is the
office of misinformation
which provides the mughal prime minister
with non-magical explanations
for obviously magical events that may
have occurred in the muggle world
this division is similar to the muggle
worthy excuse committee
and they likely work quite closely
together level 5
level 5 of the ministry houses the
department of magical cooperation
the goal of this department is to create
discourse and collaborate with witches
and wizards from
other countries it is the wizarding
equivalent to the british foreign and
commonwealth office
this department is broken up into three
divisions first we have the
international magical trading standards
body
this division is responsible for
overseeing trade practices between
international magical bodies
the second division is the international
confederation of wizards
which is basically the united nations of
the wizarding world
it is an intergovernmental body and the
overseer of this division is called
supreme dumbledore was supreme mugwum
for a period of time
the third division is the international
magical office of law
which is responsible for monitoring laws
and policies put in place
by the international confederation of
wizards level 6
level 6 houses the department of magical
transportation
this department is responsible for all
matters pertaining to magical transport
there are four main divisions of this
department the first is the flute
network authority
as we know the flu network is a network
of interconnected fireplaces
bridging wizarding buildings together in
order to use these fireplaces
you need to use flue powder which this
department regulates
the second division of this department
is broome regulatory control
this division is responsible for
ensuring that people are a
riding broom safely and b their
broomsticks are in proper
safe working order it is their
responsibility to confiscate rooms they
have been tampered with
the third division of this department is
the portkey office a port key is a
magical object that allows witches and
wizards to instantly transport to a
specific and defined location
usually commonplace objects are
transformed into port keys as to not
draw any unnecessary attention toward
them
this division is responsible for
overseeing all portkey transportation
the fourth division is the apparition
test center which helps to grant
apparition licenses to witches and
wizards apparition is of course a
magical means of transportation
akin to teleportation where the user
instantly travels from one location to
another
it is a very difficult skill to learn
which is why there is regulation
surrounding it
level 7 level 7 of the ministry of magic
is reserved for the department of
magical games and sports
as you might be able to guess by the
name this department is responsible for
all wizarding sporting events
most notably quidditch and the quidditch
world cup this department is broken out
into three
subdivisions the first division is the
british and irish quidditch league
headquarters which governs all aspects
of the british and irish quidditch
league
the second division is the official
gobstones club gobstones is a game that
witches and wizards play
and this division is responsible for
organizing and planning tournaments
the third division is a ludicrous
patterns office just like in the muggle
world
a patent refers to intellectual property
introducing an idea or concept
and just like in the muggle world there
are some ridiculous patents that need to
be dealt with
this office deals with the licensing of
ludicrous patterns
level 8 level 8 houses no departments
but is the location of the ministry
atrium
ministry reception area found in a
magical brethren
and security desk we see level 8 in the
films quite a bit
most notably in the epic battle between
dumbledore and voldemort which was in
the atrium
level 9 level 9 houses the department of
mysteries
a department that we should all be quite
familiar with as it is instrumental in
books and films
the department of mysteries is
responsible for studying the mysteries
of the wizarding world
mysteries associated with love space
thought time
death and other things basically
anything that is unknown
anything pertaining to this department
is highly confidential
and those who work in this department
are referred to as unspeakables
the divisions of this department are
broken up by area of study
and includes the following the brain
room the hall of prophecy
the death chamber the love chamber the
space chamber
and the time room there's also the room
of doors which is a large circular room
where everything is black
level 10 on level 10 of the ministry of
magic exists
courtroom 10 the courtroom where all
crimes against wizard kind are addressed
the council of magical law and wise
engemot conduct hearings here
and this is where death eaters were
charged for their crimes and the
wizarding war
harry's disciplinary hearing for his use
of patronus charm
in little whinging was also held here
level 10 is also home to the muggle-born
registration commission forum courtroom
which was used for hearings pertaining
to muggleborn wizards
as well as the ministry detention area
which is a cell block that holds witches
and wizards in between trials
and if convicted before they're sent to
azkaban
and that concludes all of the levels
departments divisions
and subdivisions the ministry of magic i
thought that i knew the ministry well
but when doing research on this topic
it turned out there was a lot that i
didn't know that's it for this video
if you enjoy the content please remember
to like and subscribe
until next time it does not do to dwell
on dreams and forget
to live